is JD or exercise teacher now like he's
your guru he motivates you he's
mentoring me for her like certain life
thanks liya betting's JD I mean that's
funny but JD's he's probably got a more
[ __ ] up life than you do I don't know
where this came from
he just started texting me out of the
blue asking me or telling me about
push-ups and whatnot and I'm like you
know what I help him out as best I can
but yeah I don't know what this is all
about have you seen JD's body I mean
it's not exactly like why wouldn't you
turn to somebody who's actually in shape
not really good actually and I'm pretty
sure stick but you know just in case I I
do want to help him I like him I want to
help him as much as how do you help him
like tell me how give me an example of
how you helped him so he'll text me one
day he wrote how he forgot if he did
push-ups and I go wanna you get a
journal or something if you want to
write it down he goes oh that's such a
good idea thank you you forgot if you
did push-ups yeah and then I forgot to
get a journal I don't remember how I
forgot that day but I did I never forget
if you did push-ups like he's gonna feel
it they forgot how many he did but and
then JD taught me how do you know about
like this stretching is it stretched
before and after because your arms can
get sore if you don't work out for what
so what do you do you have that like
when he does the push-ups you watch him
on zoom and then you evaluate it oh I
did that the first time this past week
and yes but he has his dog like around
them and like I tried to say move your
dog out of the way you know he won't do
that so why don't you Benji why don't
you do your push-ups and JD can tell me
what each one is
oh right now okay all right I think I
got a just get back up your chair out of
the way and move my stomach okay the
trampoline yeah just just boom that was
so Robin Robin I'm a reason I get
translate I found out on this trampoline
you're gonna crash right through the
floor what floor are you on
[Laughter]
Pauline when I can you imagine living
below this [ __ ] guy
jumping on a trampoline oh my god he's
gonna put his head right through the
ceiling my neighbor's floor okay so I'm
just gonna go down and do it
got you okay go ahead you got to back up
so we can see it I look like a beanbag
chair with arms owed on the trampoline
okay RJD seriously show me what you do
like here it does Hey no he's barefoot
and the dog is we got problem this is
what happens the dog is always a house
that give me a number like it's good
okay his back is pretty flat so that's
good right sorry this is about eight
nine push-ups all right you know eight
nine
well germinate an eight or a nine on a
scale of one yeah yeah yeah all right I
think he's done it looks like I'm
[ __ ] my carpet
well you got an eight or a nine so you
were doing very good for thanks yeah a
lot of people they do pushups they like
arched our back up and it's nice great
vitamin but Benji Papa can I see you do
push-ups can we
[Music]
yeah I like the voice a after you do the
hit Benji Papa here you're what can I go
out and eat like eight filet-o-fish now